Буде добриво для землі.
На дні окопів високі бур'яни. Вони встигли вирости за той час, що тут, під Херсоном, проходить лінія фронту.
Для бійця з позивним Сатана це означає місяці життя під землею.
Тут українські військові сплять, їдять та чекають, коли ситуація зміниться.
Усе під пильним оком національного генія Тараса Шевченка.
Солдати тут відпочивають тоді, коли йде артобстріл. Двоє нагорі спостерігають, а решту ховаємо.
Ця війна - здебільшого війна артилерії. Обстріл військами РФ - обстріл у відповідь і очікування наступного удару.
Така стрілянина ведеться на відстані. З метою розбити позицію супротивника настільки, щоб потім взяти її штурмом.
Тут у нас дуже тяжкий напрямок танковий. Якщо вже ворог піде сюди, то будем зустрічати тут.
Нині наступають українські військові. Кілька тижнів тому вони розпочали контрнаступ і відбили кілька десятків населених пунктів.
Проте просуваються вкрай повільно.
Ми поступово звільняємо села, які можливо. От. Ми туди не заходимо, але їх там теж нема.
Ми не заходимо, щоб не піддавати зайвий раз життя наших військовослужбовців небезпеці. Отака ситуація
Щойно командування вважатиме, що озброєння достатньо, особовий склад готовий і з радістю піде вперед.
Тим часом ми їдемо на іншу позицію. Навколо - тільки випалена земля.
Отримати інформацію, скільки на цій ділянці фронту задіяно зброї, наданої Заходом, неможливо.
Але при цьому нам постійно кажуть, що її недостатньо для рішучого наступу.
Перерва після обстрілів та обід в окопах. Ці солдати живуть тут теж кілька місяців.
Нині тут, в окопах, настрій можна назвати навіть розслабленим. У боях настала перерва.
Але всі чекають, що будь-якої миті росіяни відновлять посилений обстріл.
Доти ж вони не сидять, склавши руки, розповідає боєць з позивним "Вікінг".
Ми приїхали сюди воювати, ми постійно до цього готуємося: зариваємося, удосконалюємо свої навички володіння зброєю,
намагаємося отримати нові засоби, нове вогневе озброєння всюди, де тільки можемо.
На жаль, потік західного озброєння поки що достатньо малий.
І я розумію, що багатьом на Заході, особливо в Німеччині, Франції, Великобританії, США здається, що Україна вже
накачана просто американською і західною зброєю під зав'язку. По факту це зовсім не так.
По факту те, що ми отримуємо, розходиться в штурмові й інші елітні підрозділи
й перекидається на найбільш небезпечні напрямки, зокрема на Донбаський, наприклад, зараз напрямок, який є пріоритетним.
На конкретно цій ділянці фронту, за словами воїна, ситуацію покращили, зокрема, американські самохідні установки
М109, а також причіпні гаубиці М777 разом із САУ.
Мовляв, якщо раніше українська артилерія завжди поступалася, зокрема через брак боєприпасів,
то тепер вона може проводити якісну контрбатарейну боротьбу та давати відсіч російським військам,
нівелюючи кількісну перевагу в артилерії противника.
А нещодавні удари по артилерійських базах Росії на херсонсько-миколаївському напрямку
реактивними системами залпового вогню "Хаймарс" на певний час відчутно вивели супротивника з ладу.
Вони відображаються тим, що на певні періоди часу інтенсивність артилерійських обстрілів трошки падає,
але росіяни також перебудовують свою логістику і роблять висновки із уроків, які їм дають "Хаймарси"
і дальнобійна артилерія, яку ми отримали від партнерів.
Тому, на жаль, не йде, скажімо так, в одні ворота на нашу користь. Це постійний процес, який міняється.
Так, за спостереженнями українських військових, порівняно з діями на початку повномасштабного вторгнення РФ росіяни вже змінили тактику:
замість швидких бліцкригових ударів бронетанковими групами чи колонами техніки,
елітними підрозділами, вони почали війну на виснаження.
По суті, нині окупанти роблять те, що робили упродовж останніх восьми років на Донбасі:
артилерією цілеспрямовано знищують всі укріплення на певному напрямку, унеможливлюють поставки підкріплень, озброєння тощо до певних районів
і лише після цього відправляють танки та піхоту.
І ця тактика, на жаль, достатньо ефективна, тому що росіяни просто беруть "м'ясом і залізом",
а ми вимушені брати їх навпаки - своїм інтелектом, якимись тактичними хитрощами, уловками, постійною зміною того,
як ми працюємо, ну, і знову ж таки мотивованістю.
Тому що ми набагато більше мотивовані, ніж їхня піхота, яка тут в якості м'яса, яка воює просто незрозуміло за що.
Тож наразі найважливіше в окопах під Херсоном - терпіння, просування вперед із великою обережністю та постійна концентрація.